النزاع في هذا البلد على جعلها
دائمة. وروسيا تلوح باسلحتها
تستخدم الدعم من جهة وتخدير
الجانب الروسي بالتصريحات من جهة
النووية وتظهر قنبلة القمح في
وجه الغرب والعالم. وامريكا
سفارة واشنطن الى المدينة في عام
الفين وثمانية عشر. مغازلة
محكمة يونانية قرارا بنقل
ومصادرة شحنات نفط ايرانية من
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بتمديد
الهدنة في اليمن وحث اطراف
يتم فتح النيران على ايران بهذا
الشكل بماذا تثق اليونان? رحب
جولته التي سيقوم بها هذا الشهر
الى اوروبا ومنطقة الشرق اصدرت
يوم الثلاثاء ان ادارة الرئيس جو
بايدن لا تزال ملتزمة باعادة فتح
مسؤولين امريكيين بان الرئيس جو
بايدن يخطط لاضافة السعودية الى
بالجيش الوطني الموالي لتركيا في
قرية المحسن لي بريف مدينة منبج
والفلسطيني وعرضت اسرائيل علنا
خطة اعادة فتح القنصلية التي
الشمالي شرقي حلب. قال المتحدث
باسم وزارة الخارجية الامريكية
سفينة محتجزة في ابيا لصالح
الولايات المتحدة بناء على طلب
امريكية للسعودية، حيث افادت
صحيفة نيويورك تايمز نقلا عن
تخدم الفلسطينيين بعد ان اغلقها
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب ونقل
امريكي بموجب العقوبات المفروضة
على طهران لكن ما الذي يعنيه ان
الروسية تسيطر على عشرين بالمائة
من الاراضي الاوكرانية. القوات
الروسية عن انزعاجها من العملية
العسكرية التركية في شمال سوريا
مناطق في الحسكة شمال شرقي
سوريا. من جانب اخر قوات تابعة
قنصلية امريكية في القدس. وتواصل
مناقشة المسألة مع الاسرائيليين
واشارت الى انها تأمل في امتناع
انقرة عن افعال قد تؤدي الى
تدهور الاوضاع في سوريا. في حين
يستمر القصف التركي المكثف على
لمجلس منبج العسكري عملية تسلل
نفذتها مجموعات تابعة لما يسمى
لوجانسك. اوكرانيا تتهم روسيا
بارسال شحنات قمح مسروقة الى
لن تستخدم راجمات صواريخ مارس
لضرب روسيا. زلاميسكي القوات
ورادارات ومسيرات. واوضح ان
واشنطن لن تشارك مباشرة في
الاوكرانية تدمر خمس دبابات
وثلاث منظومات دفاعية في
سوريا. الكريملين ارسال الغربية
يزيد من معاناة الاوكران. موسكو
اوكرانيا. بايدن سنواصل تسليح
اوكرانيا بانظمة صواريخ متطورة
مقتل المئة من المقاتلين الاجانب
بقصف روسي. اعربت وزارة الخارجية
واضاف ميدفيديف انه في حال
استهداف الاراضي الروسية بهذه
نووية نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي ديمتري ميدفيديف قرار
في بريطانيا. مشرعون امريكيون
يحذرون من استخدام روسيا لاسلحة
الامدادات الروسية بسبب العقوبات
الغربية. وهنا بدأت الاعراض تظهر
ان بلاده لا تشجع اوكرانيا او
تمكنها من شن هجمات خارج حدودها
واشنطن تسليم كييف راجمات صواريخ
بعيدة المدى يهدد الامن الروسي.
الصراع باوكرانيا لا بارسال قوات
ولا بمهاجمة قوات روسية، واضاف
المملكة التي قيل انها لا تغيب
عنها الشمس قد تنقطع الكهرباء
ولا اطالة امد الحرب لمجرد الحاق
اذى بروسيا. مسؤول امريكي كييب
العابرة للقارات. ليست لبنان
وليست العراق او اليمن. بريطانيا
النووية الروسية تجري تدريبات في
اقليم ايفانوفو الى الشمال
الصواريخ فلم يبقى امام روسيا
غير استهداف مراكز صنع القرار في
التايمز البريطانية. فان الازمة
الاوكرانية ادت لتفاقم ازمة
عنها ثماني ساعات يوميا. وبحسب
التقرير الذي نشرته صحيفة
الشرقي من موسكو. وذكرت الوزارة
ان نحو الف جندي يجرون تدريبات
منظومة دفاع جوي لدى برلين كل
ذلك يزيد منصب الزيت على النار.
في مناورات مكثفة اكثر من مائة
مركبة تشمل قاذفات صواريخ يارس
انترفريكس للانباء عن وزارة
الدفاع الروسية قولها ان القوات
موارد الطاقة وتعريض امن الطاقة
الاوروبي للخطر من خلال توقف
عليهم بجنون العظمة الذي قالوه
عنه. تحذير روسي. بعدما اعلنت
الولايات المتحدة هو محاربة
روسيا حتى اخر اوكراني. تسليم
كييف منذ فترة طويلة على ضرب
قوات العدو بدقة اكبر من مسافة
فهل تفعلها موسكو بردها القاسي
على هذه التدخلات ولعيون جميع
مفاوضات السلام. لتأتي المانيا
وتعلن انها ستمد اوكرانيا باحدث
متابعي قناة شاهد لتعرف ندخل
الاحداث والتطورات. نقلت وكالة
دفاع جوي لمجموعات تكتيكية من
السفن لاداء تدريبات قتالية على
شحنات من هذا النوع لا يشجع
القيادة الاوكرانية على استئناف
اطول. رد الكرملين واتهم واشنطن
بصب الزيت على النار عمدا
على السلطة ما يجعل مسار الحرب
في اوكرانيا صعبا وغير متوقع
لكنهم يستبعدون نشوب حرب نووية.
لا يتوقف الامريكان عن استفزاز
القمح الروسية. المحيط الهادئ
يغلي. افادت وكالة تاسا الحكومية
بوتين بهذه التقارير برغم نفي
موسكو لها دائما. ليردوا بوتين
التدريبات ستشمل السفن التي تبحث
عن غواصات عدو وهمي واعداد تنظيم
الروس للحرب ام انها تدريبات
روتينية? مواصلة الاستفزاز.
لمساعدتها في الدفاع عن نفسها.
وستساعد الاسلحة التي طلبتها
قلقهم من ان بوتين يشعر بجنون
العظمة بشكل متزايد بشأن قبضته
بدأ سلسلة من التدريبات التي
تستغرق اسبوعا بمشاركة اكثر من
الرابحة وقنبلته العالمية القمح.
فهل الغرب تفادي اضرار قنبلة
بعناية. وقال المتحدث باسم
الكريملين ديمتري بسكوف ان خط
الولايات المتحدة انها سترسل
انظمة صاروخية متقدمة لاوكرانيا
الغرب ولتشعل المحيط الهادئ بعد
فترة طويلة من السكون. فهل يستعد
بريطانيا يبدو ان الكهرباء ستغيب
عنها بشكل يومي. امريكا تغازل
للسرطان وتعرض لمحاولة اغتيال.
المسؤولون الامريكيون اعربوا عن
السطح والجو تأتي تدريبات روسية
هذه بعد اشتداد الحرب الباردة مع
خامسا، لكن الامر اصبح بيد
روسيا، ومع تشديد امريكا والغرب
اربعين سفينة حربية وعشرين
طائرة. وقالت وزارة الدفاع ان
بوتين كنا نستورد القمح لكننا
اليوم اصبحنا منافسين في الاسواق
تقرير امريكي وفقا لمجلة نيوز
ويك. ان بوتين تلقى علاجا
الروسية نقلا عن وزارة الدفاع ان
الاسطول الروسي في المحيط الهادئ
فلاديمير بوتين لامتلاكه ويصعب
على الولايات المتحدة اضافته الى
النووية وهي قنبلة ويبدو انه
اخطر سلاح يسعى الرئيس الروسي
ترسانتها. روسيا اكبر مصدري
القمح في العالم واوكرانيا
يفزع العالم باسره تترقب الدول
كارثة قد تفوق تداعياتها القنبلة
للعقوبات ضد موسكو يعلن بوتين
تضييق الخناق عليهم بورقته
فلسطين. فما هي الامريكان من ذلك
المملكة التي لم تغب عنها الشمس
انقرة. فهل يتم تعقيد التوترات
بين بوتين وارض ورقة ضغط جديدة.
للقمح في العالم. القمح قنبلة
نووية في الحرب في مشهد ربما
العالمية. واذا تحدثنا عن القطاع
الزراعي فنحن الان اكبر مصدر
السعودية واليونان تفتح النار في
وجه ايران. السياسة العالمية في
المانيا ترسل اقوى اسلحتها لكييف
وروسيا تتهم امريكا بصب الزيت
تقلب مستمرة. يا للعجب حرب تركية
سورية وسط انزعاج موسكو من
روسيا. سياسة عجيبة وغريبة
يتبعها الامريكان. وواشنطن ترحب
على النار في اوكرانيا. بايدن
يدعم اوكرانيا ولا يريد مواجهة
بالهدنة في اليمن. امريكا تدرس
قرارا مخالفا لاسرائيل في
الهادئ لم يعد هادئا بعد اليوم.
فما الذي يجري هناك? الامريكان
يواصلون استفزاز بوتين برغم
التحذيرات فكيف سيرد زعيم روسيا؟
يجرؤ على تحدي سلاح الغذاء حتى
الامريكان يخافونه كثيرا. المحيط
لكنها ليست سلاحا يدويا انها
قنبلة القمح يا سادة. لا احد
اخرى. فهل تزداد التوترات حدة
وتندلع الحرب بين موسكو وواشنطن
بوتين يظهر اقوى اسلحته واخطرها
التي يعتبرها الغرب قنبلة نووية